in our series the new normal we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives black friday
is usually
the unofficial start of the holiday
shopping season but for many people this
year
it kicked off much earlier actually
retailers are having early sales to
avoid
crowds in stores and to avoid shipping
delays a recent survey found
nearly half of respondents started their
holiday shopping
online by september i am not in this
category
citing boredom while at home anna werner
looks at what's shaping up to be an
unusual shopping season anna good
morning
good morning anthony well you may not
have started your shopping yet but
some major companies like amazon and
target they've already launched
big online sales already this month and
they're seeing a surge
in business meanwhile however many local
retailers are suffering so this holiday
season
they're asking customers to think and
shop small
it's just really one of a kind louisa
chirruti and nikki lindheimer opened
their tiny store domus with its gifts
and home goods in midtown manhattan
18 years ago we could have had a
teenager going to college by now
so it's like our baby but sidewalks
normally bustling with people
are now often silent it's been pretty
devastating
we have a small store on a little side
street
and we are in the heart of the broadway
theater district
theaters are closed most tourists aren't
visiting
this holiday season chirruti says
they're likely to lose hundreds of
thousands of dollars
for three and a half weeks before a
christmas
we do one quarter of the entire
year of business so each week
is really like a month and so it's going
to be a tremendous setback
the pandemic affects the local artisans
who handcraft their merchandise too
chirruti and lindheimer usually travel
the world buying goods
with a focus on paying a fair wage to
the artists
normally in december we are able to
get replenished this year i don't think
we will be able to
experts say foot traffic in retail
stores is down
and consumers are cutting spending too
around 52 percent
expect their total holiday spending to
be less than last year
and according to a recent survey nearly
half of respondents
plan to do their holiday shopping online
ariane dorell is one of them
just to be a little bit safer not just
for myself but for the people that are
in the household right now including my
daughter
and the marietta georgia mother says
she's ordering early because of a snafu
this summer
the electric jeep she ordered online in
june for her daughter's fourth birthday
in july
arrived late july was kind of more of a
lesson learned
to actually take a little bit more time
shopping for things instead of waiting
for last minute
how big of a christmas grinch could the
shipping
issue be this is going to be a big issue
ken perkins with the research firm
retail metrics says online holiday
shoppers
should start now you're looking at a
potential doubling in the number of
e-commerce orders this year
i think this year if consumers wait till
the last minute they're going to be
deeply disappointed
back at domes in manhattan the owners
say they've expanded their online
offerings through their website
and have safety protocols in place for
customers who come in to shop
they make really beautiful they hope
people will remember that smaller stores
help make neighborhoods what they are
small stores are really the
flesh and blood of the community and
this is not just a lifestyle for us this
is our livelihood
so chiruti's message this holiday season
give
the small businesses a chance
so what's the spending forecast for this
season well perkins says it really could
go
either way with unemployment the lack of
a stimulus package some people are not
going to be able to afford
to spend a lot this season on the other
hand there may be other people who are
at home they're not traveling and they
may want some retail therapy
tony i don't know which camp you've
fallen but uh i'm hoping things go in a
good direction i always like a little
retail therapy as well and i hope people
do
shop local because if you buy local it
stays local
and it's a good plan and thank you very
much